pour cela
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jonas haddad porte-parole de xavier
bertrand qui est donc candidat
évidemment l'institut re à l'investiture
l'est républicain pour l'élection
présidentielle bonsoir jonas haddad et
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous autres
noté gilles rémy chef d'entreprise vous
êtes pdg du groupe siph allant vous
faites là pascal régulièrement entre
paris et moscou puisque votre entreprise
est un acteur de référence dans
l'accompagnement commercial opérationnel
de groupes industriels français et
européens en russie bonsoir à tous les
deux et merci d'être avec nous alors on
l'a vu un quatre couvertures ou à charge
c'est le moment qu'ont plaisir contre la
russie de vladimir poutine rien pour
aujourd'hui on se rend compte et journal
du dimanche dimanche dernier c'est y est
on est officiellement de retour dans la
guerre froide jonas haddad
d'abord vous me permettrez de vous dire
que bien sûr comme vous parfois je suis
étonné du traitement médiatique qui peut
être réservé au président poutine mais
vous savez est très souvent ce
traitement il a été par exemple aussi
réservé à donald trump qu'on considérait
comme étant le grand méchant loup est
pourtant lui n'est pas russe et donc on
voit bien qu'il ya une forme en tout cas
d'une certaine presse à chaque fois de
dénonciation permanente de ceux qui ont
envie de défendre leurs intérêts et
c'est bien ça le sujet l'admirent
poutine défendre ses intérêts c'est le
président de son pays et on doit le lui
reconnaître et peut-être qu'on n'a pas à
vilipender par rapport à ça nous notre
rôle de la france c'est d'être une
puissance d' équilibre c'est de ne pas
être si vous voulez en permanence à
vouloir tacler la russie essaie de ne
pas être non plus un vassal des états
unis mais d'en être un allié un allié
exigeant et on a eu ces derniers temps
que l'exigence c'est le moins qu'on peut
demander de la part de notre relation
avec les états unis ce qu'il faut c'est
faire en sorte de dépassionner cette
relation de jaillir part de là comme
dirait le philosophe par-delà bien et
mal pour voir quels sont les intérêts
français moi je lui porte parole d'un
candidat de quelqu'un qui veut être
candidat à la présidence de la
république française et l'objectif c'est
de savoir quels sont les intérêts
français les intérêts français c'est
d'arrêter de porter en permanence
les sanctions soient la russie c'est
sympathique de se faire plaisir mais en
permanence de vouloir sanctionner en
état avec ok nous devrions pour autant
plutôt nouer des partenariats
de la même façon qu'on des partenariats
avec d'autres pays ce serait la logique
et c'est d'ailleurs vous voyez qu'il ya
énormément de gens issus de tous les
rangs politiques qui sont rendus en
hommage à colombey les deux églises en
hommage au général de gaulle c'était la
vision du général de gaulle ses dettes
cette puissance d'équilibré donc quand
ces gens-là se disent gaullistes ils ne
sont pas gaulliste la vision gaulliste
c'est d'être une puissance d' équilibre
c'était la vision de gaulle c'était la
vision de chirac ça a été aussi la
vision de nicolas sarkozy lorsqu'ils
réussissent et à dialoguer de façon
franche et honnête avec la dîmière
poutine c'est également la vision que
nous devons porter au sein de la droite
républicaine mais attention c'est pas
pour autant qu'on ne peut pas critiquer
certaines positions de la russie voilà
on va poursuivre ce débat évidemment
jonas haddad alors y'a pas que la presse
française
ce soir le premier ministre
contre je cite l'erreur tragique que
constituerait tout aventurisme militaire
aux frontières du krainer et de pologne
quand le parisien lui se demande
jusqu'où va-t-il aller en parlant de
venir poutine on est un petit peu dans
la même veine gilles rémy c'est vrai un
jeune assad a dit chacun évidemment
défend ses intérêts mais ce qui devait
justifier de voir comptines comme un
va-t-en-guerre à la limite de
l'inconscience
oui je suis pas certain que tout le
monde des gens de césaire et je suis pas
certain qu'une certaine politique
française défendre des intérêts de la
france et que la politique menée par
l'union européenne correspondent aux
intérêts des états qui la composent
aujourd'hui quel intérêt aurions nous
dans de
démultiplier politique de sanctions qui
on le sait ne sert à rien les sanctions
ont notamment les sanctions européennes
depuis 2015 sait on se tirait une balle
dans le pied on a on a limité nos
exportations a laissé la place à l'autre
aux autres et puis sur un blanc beaucoup
plus général est beaucoup plus
inquiétant en termes stratégiques c'est
qu'on pousse la russie vers une
civilisation qui n'est pas la sienne et
qui est celle de la chine donc moi je
tout à fait d'accord si on prenait en
compte nos propres intérêts nationaux et
je crois que c'est à partir de ce moment
là qu'on arrive à un dialogue beaucoup
plus constructif avec avec la russie et
puis en même temps quand on prend compte
comme premier critère ses intérêts
nationaux je pense qu'on n'est plus à
même de comprendre l'intérêt de l'autre
aussi parce que bon là je vous parle je
suis à moscou récemment la situation et
les bulles manière un peu différente
vous parliez johnson mais ce sont des
troupes britanniques qui sont quasiment
aux frontières russes avec qui ont été
renforcées la la pologne puisque la la
la la la biélorussie est un des derniers
temps corps auquel le genre tampon face
à l'ô tan les troupes françaises les
troupes américaines sont présentes dans
les pays baltes frontière même de la
russie l'ukraine qui est un pays en
faillite
ou là où la jeunesse fui le pays qui ne
nous re perspective qui est qui a un
intérêt évident à maintenir l'attention
pour pouvoir recevoir des firmes des
financements et des armes occidentales
ukraine c'est la frontière russe
imaginons une présence est absurde et
peut-être vous dire mais imaginons une
présence russe des chars us à bruxelles
ou à un ou à genève ou à zurich donc il
faut en partant de cette prise en compte
des intérêts nationaux il n'atteint
économique nos intérêts politiques nous
intéresse strates et notre relation à
l'histoire la russie est une est une
vidéo fait partie de notre civilisation
européenne eh bien je pense que 1 ça
nous permet d 2
de progresser pour un autre tabou
composent intérêts et puis le mieux
comprendre nous parce que je pense qu'il
ya une méconnaissance enfin une
méconnaissance yeux c'est que ce débat
évidemment avec ses aspects gilles rémy
si vous le voulez bien jonas haddad on
en parle évidemment de cette crise
migratoire la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne c'est ce qui
fâche évidemment en ce moment vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron se sont parlé
d'ailleurs lundi au vu de la situation
ils ont se sont convenus de faire une
désescalade de maintenir un contact je
cite contacts directs personnels il
était temps pourquoi cela n'a pas été
fait avant les prémices avait pourtant
été engagées à brégançon mans il ya
trois ans déjà
c'est une ex une question qu'il faudrait
peut-être poser au porte parole de la
république en marche qui sont très
fragiles sur ces questions là en réalité
qui ne sont pas rapides qui ne sont pas
à gilles qui se disent européens mais
qui pourtant lorsque un sujet menace
l'intégrité européenne puisque quand
même lorsqu'on a un des pays qui est
membre de l'union européenne et qui
subit un véritable chantage migratoires
on n'a pas entendu monsieur macron se
positionner d'ailleurs c'est assez
incroyable regarder quand madame merkel
fait venir 20 millions de migrants on
dit que c'est formidable que c'est une
chance pour l'europe et que c'est notre
devoir d'accueillir du monde mais en
revanche immédiatement lorsque c'est la
pologne qui explique que c'est compliqué
on va dire que c'est de la faute de
vladimir poutine encore une fois c'est
pas notre sujet notre sujet c'est de
savoir comment l'intégrité du territoire
européen peut être respectés et si ça
avait été le cas et d'ailleurs le
bientôt la france pendant la présence de
l'union européenne il faudrait qu'on
sorte beaucoup plus réactif quand on est
un partenaire on se dit des choses
honnêtement mais parce que on est en
capacité d'être partenaire je rendrai
l'exemple de nicolas sarkozy parfois il
ya eu et on sait des séquences très
difficile avec vladimir poutine mais on
s'est dit les choses en tant que tel et
aujourd'hui on ne se dit pas les choses
parfois on fait la leçon aux autres et
nous ne sommes pas respectée dans ce
concert des nations alors arrêtez
d'écouter pardonnez moi parce qu'on va
poursuivre évidemment je vais vous
donner la parole à l'un ou à l'autre
c'est vrai que côté en tout cas de la
majorité il ya ce bouc émissaire est
tout trouvé je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'a dit par exemple député européen la
république en marche bernard guetta il
ya il ya une semaine
monsieur poutine ne veut pas de l'union
européenne et donc ils essayent de la
déstabiliser alors ça c'était important
de l'écouté parce que c'est vrai que
cette accusation elle revient en
permanence
déstabilisation de l'union européenne
gilles rémy est ce que c'est une
accusation un petit peu naïf comme le
disait jonas à date tout à l'heure
chacun ne défend t-il pas c'est ses
intérêts en géopolitique
il ya le grand méchant russe d'un côté
le gentil européens de l'autre c'est ça
oui mais en l'occurrence on parlait de
vous avez parlé du talent heures de la
couverture quasi unanime de l'appui de
la paix la presse française qui est
effectivement tout à fait le show et là
vous le donner la parole à bernard
guetta qui était un ancien journaliste
j'ai croisé à moscou à l'époque
soviétique dans les années 80 qui
maintenant est devenu débuté la demi
quant à lui au moins il est constant
c'est à dire il a toujours un problème
avec you soviétique la russie etc
peut-être qu'ils allaient
compenser ça me donne à penser ça mais
effectivement on est en affaires
notamment en l'occurrence un député qui
a qui manie les doubles standards quand
il était un piège lors de ce qu'il
appelait la plus belle des révolutions
et c'est à maidan effectivement on a
quelqu'un qui étaient étaient engagées
huile est engagée c'est haché champ
droit il a une constance et et mais je
pense que je pense même pas que je
représente représentatif de la de la
totalité de la république mais je pense
que c'est fini en l'occurrence une
individualité la couronne à nadal oui
j'ai vu que vous vouliez vous vous
exprimez parce qu'on le rappelle votre
candidat vous l'avez déjà
veut plutôt tendre la main à la russie 1
le général de gaulle que vous avez aussi
citer toutes à leur disait de paris ap
le divorce coke c'est comme ça peut-être
qu'on en arrivera à mieux se comprendre
c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à mieux se
comprendre mais je voulais juste qu'on
peut était un mou par rapport à bernard
guetta ce monsieur lorsqu'il était en
france faut savoir qu'elles vont devenir
député en marche il était journaliste à
libération et c'était le premier à
demander à ce qu'on accueille sans
aucune condition tous les migrants dans
notre pays mais à partir du moment
potentiellement un certain nombre
d'immigrés viennent ou pas du fait de
quelqu'un qui est proche de poutine
alors là on veut absolument plus de
migrants
si on suivait les qualificatifs de
monsieur guetta lorsqu'il était à
libération on aurait pu le traité de
facho parce que tous ceux qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec eux sont des fachos
donc vous voyez comment il ya un deux
poids deux mesures lorsque c'est madame
merkel qui en capacité d'accueillir des
migrants ou elle lorsque c'est nous la
france qui devrions accueillir tous les
migrants sans aucune condition si on est
opposé à ça on est des fachos mais en
revanche lorsque c'est potentiellement
des immigrés qui viennent par le biais
d'une autre voie à bâle assez pour
déstabiliser l'union européenne donc on
voit bien que ce en même temps permanent
cette inconstance comme on l'a dit tout
à l'heure c'est la marque de fabrique de
ce quinquennat et moi honnêtement je
suis pas là pour faire du commentaire de
la politique russe je suis là pour me
possible par rapport à la politique
française et en voyant ça je pense que
les gens
[Rires]
on a un petit point de liaison en tout
cas on a compris l'idée jonas haddad
effectivement givre émis par exemple les
états unis qui écoute les dirigeants
européens qui trahit son allié français
en l'occurrence nous dans dans cette
liste des sous marins australiens que
n'aurait-on pas dit si ça avait été la
russie
comment justement sur place les russes
vivent t-il ce type voilà de réaction de
la part des français ce qu'ils en ont
conscience aux finalement peut-être
qu'il s'en fiche tout simplement ce qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est que au rythme
où ça va bientôt ils se moqueront un
petit peu de ce que pense la france les
français et l'europe et les européens
c'est ça ce serait pour nous le plus
grave parce que l'europe et la france
hélas ne font plus rêver c'était le cas
dans les années 90 comme une politique
s'est écoulée où on l'a où ils ont eu
cette période de bain des constructions
comme on a un peu chez lui certains
rapports et donc effectivement l'europe
apparaissait comme un commun une zone de
prospérité équilibre etc mais on n'est
plus dans cette situation là aujourd'hui
l'europe vit ici comme une des dernières
régions quantité du monde qui ne défend
pas qui peut pas défendre ses frontières
cas vrai problème avec une émigration et
non maîtrisée qui qu'il ne trouve pas
son sont une leçon d'unité qui n'a pas
de discours cohérent et donc et on voit
bien en même temps avec des
contradictions qui deviennent de plus en
plus à surmontable leur politique
étrangère là là est ce que la politique
de l'europe et laisser celle de la de la
france et dans une certaine mesure de
l'espagne de l'est de l'allemagne
l'italie ou est ce qu'elle est d'aider à
poser par les pays baltes pour des
raisons qui sont les leurs ont une
relation particulière avec la russie on
a eu nos frontières qui s'est créé au
sein de l'union entre l'ancienne europe
de l'est qui étaient dans le bloc
soviétique
et l'europe occidentale les gens ne
pensent pas de la même manière et mais
en même temps ils n'ont pas non plus la
même relation entre la russie la hongrie
qui a régime qu'on pourrait qualifier de
proches de la pologne a des relations de
made by nature complètement différente
avec la russie donc cesser s'est
fragmentée c'est compliqué et surtout ça
manque de visibilité et ça manque de
lisibilité pour les ruches qui
d'ailleurs rôle moi j'aime à l'illusion
sarah vendre à faire mais ce n'est pas
je voudrais vous faire écouter une
réaction à celle d'un ancien diplomate
français eugène berguin l'auteur d' elle
a réussi pour les nuls qui est assez
attristé justement de la manière d'en
tourner les choses écouter faut la
prendre telle qu'elle est et établir les
meilleures relations
sur tous les plans on a fait des
sanctions après de l'annexion ou le
retour de la crimée et puis ces
sanctions finalement ils ont coûté très
cher à la culture française en industrie
et que finalement on a obtenu le peu de
résultats on ne change pas le
comportement d'un grand pays comme la
russie comme on ne change pas le
comportement des états unis de la chine
ou la grande bretagne donc voyez c'est
ça relève un petit peu du voeu pieux
c'est facile de critiquer poutine
puisque on lui on lui on lui attribue
excusez moi l'expression tous les péchés
d'israël donc
il est démoniser en quelque sorte on
voit la manne poutine partout voyez
lui-même il le dit avec sourire tiens il
s'est passé quelque chose dans un tel
pays ah bah c'est moi qui est
responsable alors que pratiquement voit
très bien que et il n'est pas présent
partout où ils peuvent à tout contrôler
y en a ça va d'un agenda qui faisait
justement allusion à ces sanctions dont
vous nous parliez aussi vous tout à
l'heure on s'est tiré une balle dans le
pied avec cette politique de sanctions
il est temps que ça s'arrête c'est en
tout cas la position des républicains et
de xavier bertrand
il est temps qu'on a un dialogue qui
soit franc et voyez ce que ce que dix
autres autre intervenant juste avant on
ne change pas le comportement d'un grand
pays comme la russie mais en revanche
keynes quenu nous constatons c'est qu'on
en train de changer le comportement d'un
grand pays comme la france la france les
plus respectés parce que la france ne
respecte plus ses alliances
traditionnelles son rôle de puissance d'
équilibre la france est aujourd'hui
humilié par certains aspects par la
politique du président actuel voyez par
exemple quand erdogan se permet de
traiter le président de la république de
malade mental quand un certain nombre
d'autres pays se permette de tapoter sur
la cuisse de monsieur macron comme l'a
fait monsieur byden pour lui expliquer
que tu es bien gentil mais mon garçon
mais au final en réalité c'est c'est
nous qui décidons
ce rôle à nous nous sommes en train de
changer notre comportement et encore une
fois je veux pas être franco français
est autant cocorico mais si nous tenions
notre rang ce genre de discussions
seraient plus constructive et on
pourrait en conséquence décider
éventuellement de levée des sanctions
jamais le mot de la fin pour vont
évidemment tant que homme d'affaires
entre paris et moscou c'est ce que vous
souhaitez aussi
au prix cher parce que je suis dans le
très impliqués dans le commerce
international et les commerces éclats
avec la russie mais c'est l'intérêt de
la france en général de notre industrie
notre agriculture ça me fait mal de
sortir de passes et 2 par un magasin et
de voir que tout les fraudes les
fromages maintenant du camembert auront
des imitations russe et que les convois
des petits drapeaux suisses parce que là
c'est la suisse n'est pas concernée par
ces contres sanction assez douloureux je
reviens sur le nous avons nous une
rupture quand même dans la relation de
confiance qui s'étaient tissés pendant
des dizaines d'années n'oublions pas
parce que l'on la campagne électorale et
dans la relation de la russie on est
content d'eux on y reviendra c'est
mistral une strate s'éteint c'est une
c'est une rupture delà de la parole de
la confiance et ça a des conséquences
qui se mesure encore au long du et
peut-être pas seulement réussi
d'ailleurs
dire que quand comme tous les états unis
sont remontées de cette manière avec
l'australie l'aurait-il fait avec un
pays qui a toujours respecté ses
contrats en matière d'armement aurait-il
fait de la même manière
merci merci beaucoup en tout cas tous
les deux il démissionna sadate d'avoir
été avec mon direct sur rt france ce
soir